11 years
ago you your sister 14 14 years ago MH
your sister your nephew and yourself
made this courageous decision to step
forward and say our family has suffered
from mental illness at a time when very
few people were talking publicly what
led to this decision for the family my
sister Jesse uh my youngest sister uh
always the wild one my dad who was a
doctor actually said pull up your socks
get back to work get an education she
came up to me on one summer um having
put her kids in the car and she said I
need your help I can't stop thinking
about killing
myself I was in shock I had
absolutely no clue no clue of what she
would was dealing with so my mom and I
were able to get her
help her
son
kayn uh suffers from
schizophrenia lives with schizophrenia
and and together they came to me and
said we have we're trying to learn how
to manage our illnesses which in
long-term recovery means you CH you you
have to change meds it's it's how many
meds is what
uh it's a process and it's a long
process and you have to be very
resilient um but she said they said we
have found that the stigma around what
we are dealing with can be worse than
the diseases themselves when kayn came
back from two years in a psychiatric
hospital hospital none of his friends
came
back they still haven't come back even
though he's become this Advocate it's
just it's incredible to me so I said
because they're my my family I said of
course I will help you um but you have
to do it with me CU it's not about me
it's about you and it's about our family
but their their courage still brings me
to my
knees um because no one was talking
about it and yet this silent epidemic
which it still is in many ways continues
so you and your family took another step
you you founded an organization called
brain change to
mind I learned about mental health
advocacy at Fountain House in New York
and when I we decided to that I wanted
to do something I wanted to start an
organization many generous wonderful
people who had their own organizations
the head of Fountain House included sat
in that library and and one of them went
online and said what what's available
what's available oh bring change your
mind okay let's use
that I mean I didn't even know I had to
have a
board so
uh I think many people recognize that
moment um and that was oh my gosh that
was a huge ad adventure and I thought
that my my main uh contribution would be
making PSAs and things like that we have
evolved d uh we now have established
over no it's
540 clubhouses in 43
States and the thing that I'm very proud
of are the kids because it's
peer-to-peer it's not high schools that
write to us it's the kids that write to
us the kids say we want we need a bring
change to mind Club in our high school
and um I've met a lot of them and they
are
phenomenal and that is transformative
yeah there's at Le I think there's about
14,000 kids now um with you know a
waiting list
always so providing this kind of
peer-to-peer experience especially among
teenagers where the suicide rate and
other forms of mental illness have been
just escalating with a big big First
Step yeah but you took it beyond that
you went to Washington you talked
publicly about the lack of resources to
treat uh families suffering with mental
illness there were some accomplishments
right there have been some sucess yeah
no it's actually very very exciting and
we're at a point uh where our government
has a bipartisan bill um they have put
aside $8.5 billion in the next 10 years
to establish what we're calling what
they're calling um certified community
behavioral health clinics in every state
of the union in whatever town or or
County uh needs them um look into it
because we all should have it in our in
our counties at least in our towns if we
in our cities um because actually we're
in a crisis of care and Glenn I know
that you were you were the first to
always say about this subject I'm not a
mental health expert I'm not a doctor I
came into this for very personal reasons
um but I'm sure there are many people
listening to us today who are thinking
are there signs are there symptoms are
there things I should look for you said
yourself you didn't realize how much
Jesse was s suffering oh what what Clues
what things did well first of all I
think Jesse my sister Jesse wrote a book
called
resilience she's so incredibly honest
and she she talks about her own Journey
with bipolar disorder but also her son
when he had his psychotic break at 19
she didn't know what was happening she
didn't know what was going on you know
he was thinking the television was
speaking to him he was afraid that the
CIA was outside she had no clue and he
would you know he'd be like this and it
was a friend of hers who had taken psych
psychiatry in college who said Jess let
me spend a little time with him and she
said I think he has
schizophrenia
and it was because of that friend I mean
Jesse would of course if that friend
hadn't stepped up I'm sure you know
found some answers to his behavior yeah
um but that was that's
actually uh I think people hopefully are
learning about that kind of thing and
but I think it's it's the the it's the
anxiety it's the depression it's uh
suicidal ideation it's food disorders
that people can so easily hide and the
thing you need to be uh uh uh Vigilant
about is a change in behavior that lasts
over like yes you we all can be
depressed for four or five days and the
weather changes you've lost a boyfriend
or you know God forbid someone has and
you're you're mourning a death but this
is this is different and when you
observe that you have to say are you
okay and even if they say
yes and you feel
differently you have to say it again are
you
okay until you get
what's happening and how are they today
Jesse and oh
Jesse
Jess I I almost hate to use the word
because it's so overused but Jesse is my
true hero both kayn and Jesse I have to
tell you she
weeps the meds are hard she has empyema
she was a wild woman and smoked a lot of
cigarettes but she weeps and says I
don't want to be this way um and the
meds they're going to shorten my life
and she has six
grandchildren now that's
hard it's hard
and sometimes I say which she said to me
once I guess I'm the
family uh what is it Black Sheep No I
guess I'm it's not the experimental lamb
I forget the word anyway um um why out
of all of us was it her why was it kayn
um we've we've we've learned so much um
but so for her for she I live across the
yard from my sister when I'm home I'm
over there all the time pppy my
dog kind of has a thing going on with
one of her little
dogs he won't admit it but uh it's
obvious
and I try you know try to get her out of
the chair you know let's go for a drive
you know do you want to go walk around
the block uh let's get our other sister
and you know it's just try to to get you
know movement and light and um so it's a
it's a constant thing now kin is a
beautiful man he's married to he's
married he's been married for I think 10
11 years and he's a painter he's a
painter and um
he once early on after he came out of
the hospital and he was brave enough to
go uh to a to a local art class he he
decided that he should tell the teacher
that he was living with schizophrenia so
he got up his carage and he said sir I
just want you to know that I'm living
with
schizophrenia and the teacher
said don't come
back he is a fabulous
painter this these stories that they do
remind us of how big that stigma is
still as one of the biggest barriers to
people getting the help and Glenn there
just such gratitude that we all feel for
the courage that you had and your and
you're I know but you fought for your
sister and for J for your nephew and for
all now we got to scale it out we have
to scale out these these Community
Health Care System we have it's a crisis
of care you know the the treatments are
there and they work and people can
recover but you can't just treat people
when they have a break and you give them
a couple of meds you've got to you've
got to be in it for the long haul and we
have to have structures like that across
our country and because of your work we
will have more and because of the work
of bring change to
mind
[Applause]
peppy here you are can here you
are th this this is Mr pip
[Laughter]
[Applause]
everyone I think this is your mental
illness companion it is do you have
anything to say you want to speak what
good job thank you
everyone thank
you